you need to make sure you let them know
that's not what's driving you okay yeah
oh hey man thanks for the call and you
are doing good stuff man doing great
stuff all right in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions the headquarters right here CJ
and Lauren are with us hey guys how are
you
we're great it's an honor to have you
guys what are you for you from Auburn so
are you all burn fans I have two degrees
from Auburn and he went to Alabama have
one from Alabama so is this a house
divided yes but we live in Auburn and we
owed Auburn more money so I always say
all in one so I just got an email 10
minutes ago that the Auburn athletic
department has decided to teach our
college curriculum to all the athletes
at Auburn and they just signed it up
just this week so well congratulations
you guys you're here to tell us you're
debt-free story how much have you paid
off a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars Wow and how long did that take
thirty four months good job making what
kinds of money when we first started it
was sixty three thousand then eighty six
thousand and now one hundred and six
thousand way to go what do you guys do I
teach second grade
mm-hmm and I'm a director at a hospital
very good so how old are you two I just
turned 30 October the 1st and he'll be
30 in April way to go and you're
debt-free yes so what was the student
loans and what else
$10,000 on a car and then one hundred
five thousand in student loans okay so
what happened thirty four months ago
this got this whole thing started we got
married three years ago today through
your wedding anniversary anniversary
thank you and you know the next day
reality sets in and you're you know you
have this awesome wedding and then you
sit down with the numbers and so our
debt free freedom journey began the day
after we got married so you after the
marriage you sit down look at the
numbers you have an oh crap moment
Sallie Mae doesn't care about our
wedding we had to get real with the
numbers and so we did very cool so how
did you that how did that what did you
do what was your first step what would
you how'd you get this going
well we gotten same page got on budget
and first and foremost ask God to help
we still continued to tithe and trust
him and he
he did it all very cool and we have
calculated that it would take us a lot
longer yeah you know when we first ran
the numbers it was gonna take us sixty
six months God did it in 34 months Oh
like cut it in half mm-hmm yeah so you
guys got intense obviously and so how
did you get plugged into us I had taken
the class in 2009 I was still in
graduate school and we got engaged
shortly thereafter and so the wedding
came and we paid deposits and things
like that and so the program got put to
this side and then just following your
show and Instagram watching the people
do their screams were so inspirational
and it just kept us going through our
journey and and so when we got married
he knew about you and had listened to
your show on the way tuned from work and
we decided to plug in and and do the
program and now we laid at an FPU course
in our home Oh through our church so oh
we're late so I'm sure they're all
tuning in a small group oh good for you
guys
very fun Chris had you have any words of
encouragement for those who maybe during
you 34 months I know there was probably
some seasons where you were struggling
discouraged frustrated like whatever I'm
just gonna go back and go back to the
old way of life what how did you get
through all that I don't know just they
discipline and get asking God for it and
then he'll make things happen and you
see the results happening and um just a
discipline we adopted a verse as well
Bible verse that we clung to and we
framed it and had it an insight so that
we could keep relying on that and
relying on God's Word and he did it what
was the verse it was in Isaiah we were
gonna get you to sign it just talking
about building streams through the
desert through the wilderness he is the
strain through the wasteland and we we
believe that and clung to that and he
was our stream through our desert of
financial you know turmoil so that is so
neat there is this mystical thing that
happens between your hard work and his
blessings yeah and that both of them
have to be present in order for these
successes to occur and to occur at this
kind of speed I mean you didn't sit
there and do nothing and he just shipped
you money you've been working your butts
off and sacrificing and he's blessed it
it's both things going on so
congratulations you Congrats very very
well done so you tell people the key you
were saying CJ is the budget
right yeah you know stick with the
budget you make more money that means
more money you throw at death the budget
doesn't change and then we just date
this point stayed with it because your
incomes went up like 40 percent during
this time
that's his income yes and God kept
blessing but really also just having to
learn to say no I mean we're young and
we have a lot of friends that want to do
a lot of things and take a lot of trips
and go out to eat I think our big thing
was going out to eat it was killing our
budget and so we just had to say no a
lot and we got weird we were weird and
our friends started kind of embracing
our weirdness after a little bit and
well now you're 30 years old you paid
off 115 thousand dollars that makes you
officially weird yes you are not normal
at all you're anything but normal normal
broke out of control and fighting about
money every week that's right well
congratulations very very very well done
all right CJ and Lauren Auburn Alabama
house divided when it comes to football
but not when it comes to knocking out
the debt a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars paid off in 34 months making 63
up to one hundred and six count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
very well done
oh man that's fabulous absolutely
awesome
you